it
is the beginning of november 2020 and
it's already kicking off to
quite a tense month because of the
election stuff
so i'm gonna take a little break and
we're going to do our monthly
update video in which i'll talk about
what went on in october
quite a lot and what we've got coming up
in november
which is a little bit less but also
still
quite a lot of interesting stuff so
i always like to begin by talking about
three big things
big thing number one is october was you
know a major month for everything
stoicism related
i was in several different stoic stoicon
x's as well as organizing the stoic on x
midwest so there's a lot of videos that
i'm linking to below
that you can watch from all of those
events
big thing number two we've got coming up
this month
at the very end of the month we're going
to be going back into ursula k le guin's
earth sea but now we're going beyond the
trilogy to the next
three books in the series that rounded
out
and and really add a lot to that world
big thing number three
we've got our classic metal class coming
up a little bit later this month
and this time we are going to be talking
about the new wave of british heavy
metal
one of the really major movements that
that put it
on you know the genre back on the map
you could say so i hope you can join me
for that classic metal class uh in two
saturdays
okay so what went on in the month of
october
as i mentioned there was a lot of stoic
related stuff we had stoic
week we had uh the main stoic con
i actually spoke at two different
stoicon x's in addition to organizing
the big stoicon x midwest here
you know cited in milwaukee but covering
all those places there's videos
you can watch of all those down below i
also did
along with scott truly my collaborator
the classic metal class and we tackled
an interesting ethical
problem that arises about the ethics of
doing farewell tours and it not being a
farewell tour
i did my normal ama that's ask me
anything session i also did a
political theory and practice discussion
focused on
what stoicism has to tell us about
politics
and then i did my usual you know hegel q
a and discussion sessions both the
public one and the
one for patreon supporters we had uh
our you know worlds of speculative
fiction
series ongoing events with focusing on
ursula k leguins
earth c trilogy which of course expanded
to be six books later on we only focused
on the
first three and we had a really great
wisdom for life
radio show session we weren't able to
get as many in as we normally do
in part because of illness on the part
of myself and
my co-host but we did have one session
where we had a special guest
michael devito a former defensive
lineman coming in we discussed rational
sportsmanship and fandom and stuff like
that so
that that's well worth checking out as
well this is a very busy part of the
semester as far as classes go
midterms you know students panicking
about
how they're doing or how they're not
doing being told by their advisors to
get in touch with all of their
professors
lots and lots of content developed on my
part i probably shot over a hundred
course videos for between
world religions biomedical ethics
business ethics and a few things for the
existentialism class
i also did shoot a lot of other videos
so there's the event videos that you can
check out
but there were also uh core concept
videos on miguel de uno numo
lev or leo shestoff and franz kafka
did an unboxing video about you know
stuff for
our cat sassy and i did a few answers to
common questions videos
and a at least one saddler's stories i'm
not sure if i did
one or two of those podcasting
some of you may have been following on
my soundcloud you know
what what's been recently there we've we
started the month with releasing the
last of the aj air
content language truth and logic then we
jumped into augustine for
most of the month and did stuff coming
from
city of god and from on free choice of
the will
and then we've been releasing stuff on
jon stewart mills utilitarianism over
about the last week or so so that's
what's been going on
this last what we've got coming up
we have quite a few events coming up in
november not quite so much
as in october and i frankly i need to
take a bit of a break between
uh you know the grueling teaching
schedule the
election all the stoic related stuff
and you know doing all this while being
sick from time to time um you know i i'm
really looking forward to thanksgiving
break
so we're gonna start out with a lot of
events
in the early part of the month and then
as we get towards the later part of the
month we have a few less
the very first saturday uh that's
saturday the the seventh
at 12 p.m ama session ask me anything
you can come in and ask me all sorts of
questions and i'll respond to them
on the seventh as well we're going to
have our philosophy chat for patreon
supporters
that's a perk for people who support at
a certain level that'll be at 2 p.m
and then at 4 p.m another wisdom for
life
episode you know you can listen to
wisdom for life 4 p.m
central every saturday it may be a new
episode or it may be a replay of an
older episode depending on what dan and
my schedule
looks like but we are recording
something new responding to
all the election stuff so if you're
interested in that you might want to
check that out we'll also be talking
about like how to
keep yourself sane during this time
then uh the next day at uh the the
eighth that is
at 12 p.m i'll have my political theory
and practice discussion i will be
talking about what to make
of of this election and i'll do a little
bit of a presentation and then i take
you know audience questions and comments
and
address and answer those on the 10th
at 6 p.m we have our milwaukee sofia
meeting this is open
because we're online to people outside
of milwaukee of course we've had people
coming
as far away as brazil and we're going to
be talking about resilience which may
also be useful
given the results of the election
on the 11th at 5 pm i'll be having my
my public hegel q a and discussion
that's you know underwritten by my
patreon supporters but you don't have to
be a patreon supporter to show up and
talk about hegel german idealism
philosophy
i do that as sort of a public service on
the
14th that's the second saturday at
12 p.m scott taruli and i will be
having our next session of the classic
medal class and we're going to be
talking about
we'll probably devote more than one
session to this we're gonna be talking
about the
new wave of british heavy metal so if
you aren't familiar with it that's bands
like
iron maiden saxon diamond head
venom raven all these great bands that
were so
massively influential and we're gonna
we're gonna talk quite a bit about that
um then on the 19th i'm not quite sure
if we're going to be doing anything for
sophia that depends on my co-organizers
but it is world philosophy day so
there's
probably going to be something
interesting going on i might do a little
you know
event of my own you know just get on
youtube and
and let people ask questions on saturday
the 28th we're going to have
two events going on so earlier in the
day
we'll have at 12 o'clock and at 1
30 the world's a speculative fiction
series discussion now i give you two
times for that because the
first time is actually a video premiere
of me
you know discussing the ins and outs of
books five four five and six of the
earthsea
series and you can engage in live chat
and i'll you know
chat back with you on that as you're
watching that video for the very first
time you can be the first people to
watch it
and to comment on it then at 1 30 we
have a zoom discussion so
video conferencing much more intimate
that's for people who want to have you
know
more discussion about these these great
novels and short stories that that she
created in the whole world
then a little bit later that day on the
28th
at 6 pm we'll be having the milwaukee
stoic fellowship
monthly meeting which we're discussing
antonio maccaro's great book on buddhism
and
and stoicism you don't have to be from
milwaukee to join us with that again we
have people from all over
the place who because we're online join
up with us
and that is going to be uh quite
interesting
as well so that finishes out the month's
events
what do we have going on in terms of
videos well i still have one more kafka
video to release i'm going to be
releasing some
some videos on marcel that's gabriel
marcel
and his on the ontological mystery i
shot some new videos from my
existentialism class
i have to shoot some videos on simone de
bevoir on the ethics of ambiguity so
you'll see those coming out
and then i'm hoping to get to the the
videos on albert camus
i have some more stuff on myth sisyphus
to shoot as well
i'll also be doing you know the
personally oriented sadler stories
i'll do some more of the answers to
common questions about stoicism
hoping to get some half hour hegel
videos shot now that things are starting
to settle down
a bit as far as the semester goes and
we've got a nice break coming up
and uh some book review videos i'm i'm
really behind on book reviews and i'm
going to be shooting some of those
as well and then finally you know there
will be videos from the various events
like the classic metal class the
earthsea as i mentioned
and of course the ama and political
theory and discussion
as far as the podcast goes i've still
got some mill utilitarianism
stuff to release after that i will
probably be working on some de bevoir
things from the second sex
and i also have some some stuff from
hegel the self-consciousness section
that i'd like to turn into podcasts
as well so that is what is going on the
rest
of this month of november
going to be you know pretty busy month
but also a time to start
winding down as we get closer to the end
of the year so i hope you can join me at
some of these events
you